by the way what you guys hear about
is simone biles oh yeah i heard she got
taken off the olympics yeah just now
like uh
30 minutes or an hour what's going on
injury no no no anxiety
mental mental pressure mental anxieties
it's real out there
was this common 10 years ago 12 years
ago in the olympics
anxiety depression i had anxiety and
depression when i played but we just
drank it away
like that was you know i'm actually
being serious i am being serious yeah
i am an alcoholic literally
self-medicated that's why there's so
many
uh i don't know i i think that uh look
media scrutiny is is
different it's just different i've never
had media scrutiny at this level
well more than media scrutiny it's all
the commentary that comes with the media
scrutiny yeah
if you read in the comments it's i could
get ugly i've learned the hard way do
not
read the comments i will tell them good
or the valuetainers
the valuetainers i will say are very
interesting at least in the comments
they're very funny i do whether they
whether they like me or they don't
they're very funny
the commentary actually is like there's
some actually legit stand up can you
actually read the comments or no not
really not really no
okay on valuetainment economics i do
there's a lot of like saved out you're
amazing
on your posts yesterday
did you see his post yesterday so he
posts a job opportunity right and we
talked about it last night why didn't i
say that the guy is notorious for taking
care of his employees right
but he puts out something he's like i
need immediate hire all right
i'm gonna i'm gonna give somebody a job
and the first thing is like you're not
paying enough screw you this and that
and
this woman comes in was like i would
never work for you and
he's like he's in the comments yes you
should see it yeah it was i believe it
was like i don't think you really fit
the culture and you're looking
you you look at her profile and it was
perfect it was perfect it was like uh
she was basically like antifa jane man
like it was like i could just imagine
her in this office place today so it was
two job postings for bookers sixty
thousand dollars oh i heard a
plus bonus plus four one k plus benefits
right can i apply
we're willing to pay relocation feeder
here this guy from dubai
says yeah it's pathetic why are you
paying them this much so what i do is i
go to
salary.com zip recruiter and different
website that tell you what
what a talent booker's salary is
in south florida it's forty two thousand
or fifty eight thousand i put sixty
thousand products bonus so
i comment back i said you haven't been a
booker before do you know what a booker
gets paid and these guys go back and
forth anyways the point is
you know one i enjoy trolls i have fun
with them
to me it doesn't bother me what bothers
me is the fact that
you know you're seeing today with
olympics
the amount of pressure that you know i'm
trying to see if this is real pressure
that athletes have on anxiety how to
deal with it is it
hey if you're doing that as well i'm
also going to do it since you can also
step out and not want to compete then
i'm going to do it because even the girl
from japan the tennis player lost
yesterday i don't know if you guys saw
them
yeah osaka's out she was she uh what uh
she wanted to take a break she doesn't
want to talk to the media
is this is this a is this something
where sports has to take seriously to
give
because she proposed giving days off
like here's the amount of days i could
have for media
is that something sports should consider
hey i got five days off today i don't
want to talk to the media about it okay
so i have two feelings on this two
feelings that that i feel pretty strong
do they both involve
alcohol no but wow okay yeah uh the
first one is man
that whenever you're doing any sort of
athletics right
and i can only imagine the in the
olympics specifically where you where
it's
four years of training for this one
moment it's it's all this pent up
aggression
most of sports and this is when when i
was playing this is what people don't
understand
like most of it sucks most of it's not
fun they see you out there and you're
hitting the ball and you're running
you're having fun and you're pimping
home runs and they're like this is fun
man
those three hours are the most fun hours
that you can have those hours under the
lights are amazing
but everything leading up to that sucks
it really does man the practice
the the the protocols depending on like
how strict the team in the organization
is
like you feel like you have no personal
autonomy at all and you're you've
given so much of your life to this dream
you you've missed
birthdays you've missed weddings you've
been away from your family you go across
the world like you
literally give everything up give up
relationships you give everything up for
this
it's it's all there but you got to kind
of find your why
so for a lot of us it's like i love my
family i've got the chance for
generational wealth like i'm i'm gonna
i'm gonna do something for my family now
with the olympics
like like it was it was the love of
country it was i'm going to represent my
people back home i'm going to represent
i'm standing up for something
i don't know if that love of country is
still there yeah i do
think that's a major factor in this
moment i think it's just the you want to
achieve greatness can you pull up the
twitter
twitter
level i can tell you the biggest
difference between college baseball for
me
and minor league baseball was i gave a
[ __ ] whether my team
won in college i loved my teammates and
i cared if we won
and in my leagues i didn't matter of
fact all i wanted to do was go to a
different team i just wanted to move up
i wanted to do well enough that i could
leave these guys behind you know what
i'm saying so i think when you
individualize your sport so much
you you end up taking all of the the
the negative too much on you because
you're not able to
you you're not able to to relish in the
team victory you're not able to relish
in
in what we're doing as a group you know
the the wii
is definitely bigger than the me when it
comes to so so the other day
sportscenter post this on july 25th on
twitter friends hands uh the u.s men's
basketball team their first loss in the
olympics is 2004 snapping their 25 game
olympic winning streak
even fournier led the way with 28 points
in uh win tokyo 2020 right okay even
though it's 20 21. anyways at the top i
put there are two ways the us basketball
team can motivate themselves to win
number one is
love of the game number two is love
their country there's a there is
where someone on the team this is where
someone on the team has to bring up the
pride of representing the great country
the greatest country in the world this
only works if they actually believe it
now go above to the tweet above it
go right above it and see what's right
above it keep going keep going keep
going keep going keep going right there
uh luca donage went off for 48 points in
his olympic debut donation slovenia
defeat argentina 118 to 100 and the
country's first ever olympic men's
basketball game
when asked what would it mean what would
mean more to him winning an nba
championship or gold medal for his
country
his gold medal for his country he said
the gold medal for his country right so
because he's got a love and pride for
his country look it's very hard if
you're coming off of 2020
with covet and everything took place and
what are you fighting for
what does a gold medal really mean now
they're talking about hey you're going
to have to pay this much taxes because
it's gold and you're coming back and
everything is diminishing the value of
winning
for your country go to the metal leaders
go to the metal leader right now i think
u.s is at 22. i think u.s and china
yeah china's trying to make a point here
kai you just have to put metal count
2020 olympics you're writing a paragraph
oh my god buddy just go back and i'm
telling you just write metal count u.s
olympics medal
count u.s that's it this is how far he
has to go to find a medal for norway
should be all the way at the top there
you go okay so we got what oh japan's
got the most gold they just passed them
up
right now by the way that's a 30 minute
united states number one over 24
then it's china 21 then it's roc which
is
russia uh at 18. by the way armenian guy
won the gold medal yesterday in april he
had an achilles heel
he tore his achilles heel in april in
april he tore his achilles heel